welcome back to the Julian podcast this
episode is brought to you by postman get
post mates right now order we already
did today but a post main Stockholm / -
no Julian use coach Angelina post mates
happy $100 off free delivery credit here
for seven days great food all your
favorite restaurants loaded right chiodo
also guys the skin do you want to know
things hey what the hell do you want to
know things the skin helps you know
things all the important news stories
going on the world the skin is a daily
newsletter that comes in your email for
free and lets itself in but at the skin
th tsk mmm - in stockholm / san julian
somebody free I'll see you sign up to
win a Visa gift card or 250 dollars or
euros worth a different amount because
the exchange rate is a little scuffed
also guys feed your dogs farmers dog the
farmers dog is the best way feed your
pets they give completely custom-made
meal plans for your pets that will be so
delicious that they're just gonna bother
you all day because they want dinner so
bad ours do it to us go to the farmers
dog calm slash and Julian get 50% off
your first two weeks I am too tired for
this he's falling off tails hanging off
the bed he's like a little clock tells
fine no no like his left butt cheek is
falling off of his bed he's fine like
you know he's ya know I got you I'm
lookin to new tattoos and to do my
favorite part of Halloween is seeing
someone teach their young child how did
make that noise and then recording them
on their phone someone tweeted that it
yeah is Instagram story i reposted
speaking of tweets oh my god today was
such a great day y'all such a great day
I'm so tired I wanted to get a nap we
didn't really sleep a lot last night we
we had a little celebration yeah we
celebrated Brett's birthday our friend
Brett
by consuming things like alcohol and
more alcohol less than so and then not
sleeping very much but I'm laying in bed
it's like 9 a.m. and I'm on my phone
just barely waking up like just looked
at my phone just kind of scrolling
through Twitter and then all of a sudden
a new tweet pops up on my feet and I'm
like what where did this tweet come from
and it was Jenna I was like wait what
Jenna just tweeted like 20 seconds ago
and I look I look to my left and she's
[ __ ] out like I thought she was just
completely passed out and I'm like what
what the heck and I lean like further
over her body and I see her phone is on
on her back like screen facing her back
in Twitter her back tweeted twice this
morning and I start busting up I'm like
dying you just tweeted wake up and she's
like dying it's so weird to like it's
like a bunch of L's and words like like
I'll read them there's a the first tweet
is life like LPL LPL LOL LOL p LOL like
that's a word like i must have been
hitting like the keyboard where it like
autofills and words you know and then
you next week was LA and like the
funniest part obviously is because
Twitter is so funny and you guys are so
funny he's like just the replies are me
any people started responding
immediately and then someone tweeted
this or they quote tweeted the one that
says law and have you seen this people
were like big same mood yes
like half of the people thought I stole
your phone and just tweeted nonsense no
well I woke up and I was like I'm gonna
delete on I was gonna like tweet what
happened first and then delete him and
then you're like no leave a box like so
embarrassed she was like let me tell you
I was like nah you got to leave him out
there so good I fell asleep on Twitter I
was reading about the smog in India in
Delhi about how awful it is right now
and the air quality I remember that was
like the last thing I read it must so
just like dozed off and then the next
thing I know you're like you just
tweeted and I'm like oh no it is like
one of your fears though to accidentally
like go live or tweet while your phones
in your pocket yeah that's I mean it's
yeah but it's I just mean like you're
the proverbial your fear like it's
everyone's kind of like I hate to like
tweet from my pocket or go live when I'm
eating spaghetti really anything so that
was dope hell yeah dude my dude killing
it up in the I know you're really otteri
and tired I'm saying I'm the same way
like I I never sleep all off air drink
just literally I can't ever get good
sleep who knows I was up late talking
and then the next thing you know I wake
up like a couple hours later and then I
was like that was not a full night's
sleep cuz I was rudely awoken by years
myself tweeting oh man well we got bunny
in the room bunny in the house shouts
out bunny she's children you know what's
funny is she loves this spot in the
podcast room but she doesn't quite know
when we're podcasting and we're not so
every time she comes upstairs she just
walks to the podcast room and it'll be
like a Tuesday right bunny it's not
podcast know what podcasting today write
that in there that I like I would like
to go podcast yeah
no no podcast today poor bunny slipped
and fell in the pool the other day she
uh we we were we were chilling in the in
the room downstairs that has the door to
that the back the backyard and Jenna
heard the splash so we ran out and she
was just getting out of the
she fell in a hot tub but we had to
check the tape the security camera to
see what had happened and basically she
was running along the side of the pool
where there's not much room it's like
the edge of the pool and then the fence
to the neighbor school Erin and she's
probably chasing a squirrel's I mean she
runs along it and her foot slips into
the pool while she's running and to like
kind of compensate back her balance to
get back out of the pool she like jumps
into the hock sometimes into the hot tub
like she's already moving fast and like
I think she like you know scraped her
leg a little bit a hot tub
she was never underwater she was like on
the side where there's a seat in the hot
tub yeah I was walking along there but
then because she has really tissue paper
thin skin since when she went to go pull
herself out of the hot tub she scraped
both of her knees yeah I've never met a
being with such thin skin mm-hmm
and be so tough and so thick thick but
like seriously the toughest dog ever
she has never even so much as like cried
once
not a single peep out of her from pain
and she went through a really gnarly cut
on her foot and then she fell in the
pool and like I know I heard it like
right away and by the time I ran out
there I saw her like getting out of the
hot tub and shaking off and I'm looking
at her and I'm like [ __ ] oh you [ __ ]
wet right now so anyway okay where were
you I look at the pool and it's like
splashing like what did you just do
because remember she used to go in the
pool go in the pool during the summer it
wasn't it like kind of warm so I thought
maybe she like just you know let herself
in the pool and went for a little bit
but no she slipped into the hot tub and
then pulled herself out oh yeah she's so
cute she's doing really well by the way
I know you guys a lot of you uh you're a
lot of the comments on my videos lately
I've been like bunny update please cuz
I'm just cooking in the kitchen now and
I'm doing videos where you don't really
you know it's not like a vlog and then
Jenna if you don't see her in Jenna's
video really what's the update she's
doing great you know like she's we were
I was we were talking about the other
day she had such a good day the other
day she was so like present and excited
and happy the whole day got a tail
wagging tail wagging she does this thing
about what she should we call it
spamming more I taught her more yeah so
tell them what's spamming more
well she's really here when she's laying
on the ground somewhere shall she
started you can see it in some videos
where she started doing this thing
because she likes the inner thigh rubs
so she'll lift her leg up and she wants
you to scratch her inner thighs or pet
her inner thighs or she really likes her
neck and like her head her ears and my
kind of stuff so I'll walk up to her
she'll go like this I start petting her
and then I wanted her to like she seemed
like she was enjoying it right yeah like
let's establish a communication here
because peach does it all the time like
these guys know how to ask for attention
yeah I want it so wanted her although I
really like the I roll over and lift my
leg up I don't I don't know when you
want me to stop or if you would like me
to keep going and I bother you you know
you let me know because because bunny
does have a limit she doesn't like to
just endlessly get pets she's like okay
I'm good yeah and she's also a dog that
appreciates a little bit of space yes I
don't think she needs to be like CUDA
and touched constantly like I think she
likes being left alone she does yeah so
I wanted to give her the opportunity to
communicate with me how much pets she
would like so what I started doing was
petting her and then stopping and then I
would take her hand and I go you want
more and I would like you know hold it
or put it on my knee or like go like
this and then Pat her some more and then
stop and hold her pot like essentially
teaching her how to go like pause she
goes like this if she was like some more
pets it's like it's like pulling the
lever
it's like she's yeah she's so obviously
so smart that she just learned that and
like you know 20 minutes yeah and so now
I was like the first couple times I did
it I was like she's so sweet because
she'll I'll pet and he go you want more
and she'll go like this I'll be like wow
you know do a little bit more and then
she was kind of done and like that's so
sweet
you know she doesn't spam it but she's
not over here like spam and more peach
stands more but like the last few days
she's been spamming more it's like even
more my goodness
petter some orange she's like look ma
yeah my my that's like oh no I regret
more yeah like she does spam it she does
however like semana to a limit peach if
you let her she would spam it until she
fell asleep endless endlessly she like
cannot get enough attention if you're
petting her she'll grab your hands while
you're petting her like neck and then
you stop and she'll just be like get the
[ __ ] back over it you have my paw on
your phone everything like that
yeah I've never met a dog I mean I've
seen them but I've never actually met a
dog that like will physically grab your
arm and hold on I know yeah it's it's
wild it's it's like a Muay Thai clinch
yeah it's like when a Muay Thai fighter
has the back of an opponent's head
that's what she does to your arm
she's like you're not going anywhere I
got you now she does that thing like if
you're doing something with your hands
that isn't paying attention to her
she'll pull your hand off whatever with
her hit with her hand or she'll stick
her nose like yeah if there's this much
room underneath your hand and a surface
she'll get her nose under there so then
you're petting her without ever petting
her she's just like pet herself with
your hand oh yeah buddy learned more so
she's been getting so much attention
because now she's really confident and
more she's like I want more she's so
confident what a confident girl she's
gonna sleep with her crate open now
mm-hmm oh yeah we do we she started to
have you know like her progress is like
random I would say she'll have like
random days where she's making really
great progress and then of course she
has days where she struggles a little
bit like recently she was struggling
with night time she didn't like all the
sudden she just didn't want to come
upstairs to bed we would put her in her
crate once she came upstairs and shut it
like we normally do and she would didn't
like being in there she would like bark
and like literally bark at night like we
were trying to go to sleep she would
bark so we're like okay this is not
working she want to get out of crate so
we just started opening up her crate and
opening the door to our bedroom to the
house so that if she wanted she could
just kind of like wander downstairs and
sleep down there a little bit a couple
of times and she did that she would like
go to her spa in the stream room and be
like I'm gonna sleep down here I need
this you know I need this area right now
and then she would kind of come up at
like 3:00 a.m. I would hear her come up
go back yeah she moves like such a funny
cadence yet like GE I wonder who that is
coming up the stairs her feet are so
loud on our floor with you loud as her
bare paws and then she's you know so we
just we stopped shutting her crate which
is really great because I think she
feels a lot happier she feels safe
because she has like the back the den
part of the crate covered but it's like
trapped in there and yeah but but she's
also good about staying in a lot great
when we leave the house yes
Whittle Kong like she's so good at that
it was just night time she wasn't
feeling like one so now when we're
sleeping in there cuz you know we're a
little nervous to leave her crate open
at night because we have little dogs
that go creep it around in the middle of
the night in the morning and you know
they do go creep in it's Kermit he
creeps around I don't know what he's
doing he like creeps or whatever he's
but I'm like you know would that bother
bunny would she get up you know what are
they gonna be interacting while we're
not awake which you know not we try to
avoid to the best of our ability just in
case but I'm like we just decided we
were like yeah let's try it sleep with a
crate open and it just makes her feel
like bet you can tell because even when
in the morning you you'll get up you'll
bring her downstairs feed her breakfast
and then she'll come back upstairs and
like get in her crate until I get out of
bed and everybody's like out all the
littles are out like she waits with the
pack to go downstairs and like start the
day you know but like I think there's
something about a crate that she does
like but the idea of having no choice of
leaving the crate she doesn't like yeah
you know and I think she just kind of
decided that randomly yeah it was like
one night she was in there and we were
watching TV like I don't want to be here
I'm gonna bark and that's like that was
tough it was like a I was tough for us
because we're like what happened what
happened like we we had a good thing
going you were good about the crate at
night and then all the sudden on your
parking us and it was good it was
getting to the point where like we were
we were exhausted we were leaving it's
losing a little sleep over it happened
like for a week right maybe a little
over and when we finally just like let
her out and she you know decided when
she could come and go it was a good it's
like a good thing because
I don't know it's like a sign of like
trust that we can let her around the
house at night she's not gonna do
anything naughty yeah
but she's also just prefers it that way
yeah like the times that she has slept
downstairs you get up in the morning
she's just like hey yeah like did you do
anything down here and she's like no
cool all right I was like Bonnie what
are you doing she's like I'm just
starting my day nothing I'm like how are
you starting your day and she's like
reading the skin yeah Julian come on you
were gonna laugh you like cut your laugh
off that was good keep laughing praise
me praise me in my segues thank you
thank you the skin while we're on the
topic I mean you guys you know you saw
how natural that was it just happened
this game is a great newsletter it's a
tool that you can use every day where it
sends a newsletter to your email with
all the top news stories in a very easy
to digest format it's not convoluted
there's not opinions you have to scroll
a bunch it's it's very simple it's nice
easy bite-size it's great to have with
the start of your day while you're
drinking your coffee having your cereal
whatever it is the skin is there for you
all you have to do is go to the skin th
e sk IMM comm slash Jenna Julian and
when you sign up not only do you get
free awesome news content every day and
a really easy opinion list you know way
of reading it put your sign up to win a
$250 Visa gift card with that
subscription it is awesome it takes like
five minutes you can skim the most
important news of the day let's check it
out also guys post mates the wonderful
delivery app that delivers all your
favorite foods right to your front door
or your office wherever you are post
mates is there for you 365 days a year
no drive-in no parking no talking on the
phone okay if you just have one of those
days where you can't [ __ ] deal with
being a person and interacting me all on
the app it's really amazing they had us
in mind you know who you are
they had us in mind with post mates you
get to track your order on the map it's
really great if you like need to know an
ETA it's not like you have to text
someone for need a you can literally see
their ETA because you see how far they
are from where you were getting the food
delivered marble marble wake up we had
post mates earlier today we use it a lot
it's wonderful and you can use it to buy
going to post mates COMSOL a stringent
or go to the post mates app in the App
Store download it and use
Jenna Julian $400 off free delivery
credits free first seven days and then
when your doggies need to eat just can't
farmers our dog all three of our little
dogs love farmer's dog we signed up with
him a long time ago when they joined us
as a sponsor for the podcast we logged
on and created a special profiles where
you answer some questions about your
dog's eating habits and then they
formulate a meal plan and send you the
fresh farm-fresh dog food for your dogs
that I'm telling you they're gonna love
it they're gonna love it so much it
really should have no teeth marble loves
it they sometimes they'll like jump up
and horse kick me while I'm on my way to
feed them it because they're so excited
to just get it in there no do that horse
peach does the horse kick so check it
out the food arrives at your door in pre
proportion packs which is really
convenient ready to open and serve which
makes feeding so quick I literally feed
them in like under a minute it's amazing
so start feeding your dog better today
get 50% off your first two week trial of
fresh healthy food at the farmer's dog
calm slash Jenna Julian or click the
link down below awesome stuff you know
thank sponsors she's been doing really
good and last night we had Brett's
birthday so we had six dogs here oh my
god yeah I had a lot of dogs are four
and then Brett bought bought a buzz and
Lucy and she had never met Lucy and she
was able to just like meet them
immediately like any dog uh you know in
her house and she said hello she wagged
her tail at Lucy she really liked her I
think she really likes girl dogs she
does yeah and uh her and Peach have been
getting closer to just like straight-up
gives her kisses yeah if Bunny walks up
to the couch peach will just walk over
to her and kiss her and I'm like that is
the cutest [ __ ] girls yeah that boy my
god I think they're finally getting over
that like weird female dynamic to where
at the beginning it was like who's who
here peach is so hyper beta she can not
be more baby bunny is not at the bottom
of the pack peaches are peaches the
bottom of the barrel but he's younger
than peach and newer than peach and
Peach has still found herself at the
complete
on him on the pack she's the bait has no
authority in this yeah no yeah so but
for a while peach had this like fear of
honey which was warranted because bunny
he's big energy that was not she had
different energy and also she would do
this thing where any time she saw peach
she would get excited and go towards
beach and then peach would run away
which sort of then further encouraged
bunny to chase her so it doesn't happen
much anymore but for a while peach was
just kind of scared of buddy and she's
finally gotten the point
LPG chases bunny she loves she chases
bunny around when he does his uma dusted
sometimes she'll like absolutely be so
out of her league it looks like a child
is trying to chase an NFL player because
they're both fast but bunny is just a
different anyway really good we had our
friends here for Brett's birthday and
six dogs and she's been doing better
with the TV she'll walk out like into
the main living area when the TV's on
hang out make her round say hi to people
she really likes people like when Brett
came over she gave him a kiss and she
won't leave Lexie alone our friend Lexi
why was Lexi she loved mark like it's
really it's just so nice to have a dog
that like when someone comes in the door
she doesn't do anything other than just
like walk up to that up to them and
greet them she greeted their dogs she
was like welcome to my home yeah I would
love to smell you would you like to
touch my head this is a lovely exchange
all right I'm gonna go lay down yeah it
is it's wonderful it's refreshing it's
almost like what dogs should do whenever
guest arrives
marble marble and Kermit we talked me
all new loud rats all right I'm gonna
read we had this idea to read some
holiday recipes to get what the recipes
are by reading by me reading the
ingredients so I'm gonna do a few of
them just that recipes Holiday Edition
yes it is because now that Halloween's
over it's Christmas Christmas baby Happy
Hanukkah you're Jewish I got some
Hanukkah stuff in here don't worry baby
oh now you're ruined it oh oh don't
worry you're gonna need help okay these
are tough number one here we go so tired
I know babe just guess that recipe
I'm gonna start reading ingredients now
clear washable PVA school glue wait glue
Julian some of these are crashed well
it's a recipe I looked at recipes and
this popped up it's technically a recipe
wait so if you don't know how this works
Julian's gonna read the ingredients to
something we have to guess we as than me
but you can play along good recipe my
favorite of which was what like rice and
water gruel and it was gruel yeah I have
a hard time guessing gruel sorry
Oh baby you know you got to know the
ingredients to girl you just never know
when you're gonna need the ingredients
to loosen water when the gruel hits
alright okay washable PVA school glue
this is a recipe silver and blue glitter
glue bottles silver and blue glitter do
you are you getting the color are you
getting the color scheme pointer are you
getting the color scheme yes it's
Hanukkah point your phone always half a
cup of water half a cup of liquid starch
that doesn't sound edible silver and
blue sequins decorative dreidels slime
container this is from Betty Crocker so
you know it's edible the recipes from
four and a half cups of gold metal
all-purpose flour one package of yeast
two tablespoons of sugar two teaspoons
of salt one cup of butter two eggs one
egg white
9 large yellow gumdrops that's it
them's the ingredients oh and frosting
and toothpicks that's it what do you
guess a gingerbread house but it's not
no because there's no ginger a ginger
cake
there's no it's not okay I'm sorry
cake with gumdrops on top of it a gum
cake close no making a cake not a cake
it's like pizza dough close sir pastry
dough no colder colder you were close
with pizza dough how is that helpful
that's mean savory dessert it's savory
[Laughter]
good you were close with pizza but it's
actually a menorah shaped challah bread
julienne on top those are yeah they are
there's a toothpick truck some gumdrops
stuck through them that looks terrible
looks disgusting it's pretty awful it
looks like a small bread plane that's
supposed to take flight it's like
already half on fire
that's my city dude oh yeah don't look
at my phone then point it away from me I
can't read it that way imagine he's just
someone looking at their phone like this
just thing on the side okay
here we go recipe number 14 - 8 ounce
blocks of cream cheese
guess what temperature they have to be
room good 3 half a cup three and a half
cups I mean three and a half cups of
sharp cheddar cheese gives the
temperature that has wait hold on
so you're saying it's a recipe
guess what temperature the cheese has to
be a cult no room we had it there for
one ounce package of rants ranch
seasoning mix you know one and a half
cups of crushed PP sounds piece ons
pecans I don't know I didn't know how to
say these hands these crushed pieces
gotta crush the piece ends fine to make
a recipe these is what temperature you
think the piece ends have to be yeah and
they were like bowel isn't this word are
like how what was it
ocean it was Oh though oh my god the sea
and the word ocean makes a sound and
then the oh you Oh W and shower make a
sound another word cursing makes Colonel
yeah Oh L it makes earth so he was like
so technically according to the English
language you could spell shower like it
was like sea stop if you don't if you
don't pronounce piece hands like P
sounds I don't have time for you P sins
to black olives oops
one cherry tomato literally one cherry
tomato okay that's decorative to orig
original size
completely arbitrary original size
pretzels okay
what is it cream cheese
sharp cheddar ranch seasoning piece ends
olive tomato pencils I'll give you a hit
it's [ __ ] stupid you're making like a
cheesy dip with like olive and why would
you you nailed it when I said the one
cherry tomato you said it's not that
good yeah so same with olives is it a
Santa dip no because hello Rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer Rudolph cheeseball
you did it to him look how stupid this
is oh the piece ends go on the outside
yeah the piece ends our protections are
the Cody I'm just kidding it's not
stupid if you made it this your PIN I
didn't mean it's probably very good yeah
and it's really cute I love cheese balls
they're so good like when I was a kid
they make some vegan ones that are
really good you know yeah
when I was a kid like we would go to my
aunt's house and she would always have
like the port wine cheese and so it's
like super sharp and you like stuck
there with crackers and they're like
don't fill up and I'm like this is the
best [ __ ] cheese I've ever had Anna
waited all year to eat it please they're
feeding you for free why are you mocking
them don't fill up on cheese and thank
you for having me I'm a child I had
similar experiences every time I go to
my dad's house my dad and stepmom would
put out brie cheese and that to me was
such a delight mm-hmm I had never I
remember the first time I had it I was
like I've never tasted anything like
this it is so good yeah
can we put out crackers and oh my god I
was like brie cheese was like that coupe
brie cheese and crackers was my favorite
time of day
yeah always like as a kid I loved that
so I did too
now we just on that forever quest to
find like the best to be in cheese we
can because some of it beat not so good
some of it be really bad but some of it
also be really don't good there's a few
companies actually I just I just put in
an order
I got some it's like a breed type cheese
and it's really good oh man she like
honestly that's cute that she put the
pretzels in there with the nose and yeah
reindeer cheese ball that's super cute
but I mean let's holy fooling once we
get hungry we taken all that off of this
and give me the piece ends
yeah piece ends or Oh die Oh give me
some of that piece and pie okay ready
are you ready materials marshmallows
Hershey's Kisses thin pretzel sticks
blue sugar sprinkles white frosting used
as glue and a spreader marshmallows
Hershey's Kisses pretzels you're
definitely making something decorative
what's edible but it is edible it's like
you're making a marshmallow reindeer
okay you did rain to your last time you
can't just do that same goes but like
what else has like brown legs hold on
hold on pay attention to the colors okay
blue glitter blue sugar sprinkles okay a
marshmallow menorah close [ __ ] that was
close
a marshmallow mezuzah close maybe a
little colder but still close mm-hmm
okay a marshmallow yarmulke here I'll
give you a hint
Marshall Torah he's not oh so it's
what's the other one
that's savory now that's sweet that's
sweet savory it's like I mean just like
communicate with each other on a daily
basis like that it'd be this this is the
kind of conversation that you and I
would have like over dinner one night
you go when you go yeah I mean it's
sweet and when I go it means it's savory
if you did go by do something you go you
know what's sweet ants every soldier no
you're not makeup Parks and Rec joke no
but it is a sweet and savory I'm
starting to catch on you [ __ ] yeah you
are
you're you hip
[Laughter]
[Music]
ok ah ok so I'll give you a hint it's uh
huh it's blue you guess it's Chanukah
steamed it does what a DJ does it to one
well DJ does it to him you know they had
to but what does the DJ do remix No
yo DJ play that no other word not play
pump that J no pump that Jam dump it out
I don't think you say yo DJ dump it out
yo DJ drop that [ __ ] you're that [ __ ] is
perfect you just need to switch the
first word what are they doing what are
they physically doing keep going I can
finish what is the DJ physically they're
just cute just just look at a DJ in your
brain right now knows what is he doing
what what motion Papa [ __ ] okay no he's
not he is not popping his [ __ ] he's
doing something else it's a very very
clear motion to the circular discs on
his table he's spinning yes what it does
that it's a do you though it's a
marshmallow first marshmallow
yeah Chanukah marshmallow straight Oh
YUM don't look at my Pinterest then stop
showing by the way guys all subscribed
my pictures ok I got a couple more
couple more bangers this one's probably
the biggest banger
except it's not opening open in Safari
when the Safari hits ok here we go ok
this actually doesn't have a list of
ingredients so it's making me do it for
it I'm just gonna look at it and read
there a list
whole-wheat toast three slices YUM okay
cucumber sticks or celery sticks one on
the other baby carrots
that is it good [ __ ] luck in a plate
crudité I don't know what language that
is it's such usually with some hummus or
this is you and then you pretended that
your eyes were like yeah looks like
you're crossing a little bit are you
gonna guess closed menorah shaped out of
bread terrible someone just cut bread
and then put celery sticks and then
carrot sticks on top beautiful
this one looks so bad okay it's lemon
blueberry bread recipe Oh like seriously
what is that looks good it blueberry
bread yeah it's a bagel it's different
bread no it sounds like a Seinfeld
episode it is a Seinfeld episode don't
don't
that was amazing
Thanks it's pretty good show all right
give me another one since you should
learn it out the recipes Oh
how do you spell holla CH a L I was
gonna get you with that one H right yes
I worked in a Jewish day camp okay four
sheets of matzah okay this is a
Christmas recipe four tablespoons of
pizza sauce oh it's not a Christmas
recipe it's a Hanukkah recipe that was a
joke didn't land missed half a cup of
shredded mozzarella cheese that is
literally it Massa pizza the easy crap
dude easiest clap ever except YUM that's
broccoli why was that list of
ingredients YUM fake fake fake fake okay
why do you want to do that okay yeah
okay here we go
okay here we go
you need coconut butter mm-hmm
coconut oil mmm cocoa powder mmm maple
syrup very sweet how do you say hey you
say syrup syrup no syrup people syrup
syrup maple syrup syrup syrup like a
stirrup syrup filled Oh syrup oh god are
you can are you comparing maple syrup to
a sock no syrup I don't say syrup syrup
I do not say say it syrup syrup syrup
syrup
cheer up cheer up it's like peace and
why he sands with syrup was the worst
thing ever even is this podcast
[Laughter]
syrup okay also a sifter sick a mold or
mold well you can get a mold or you can
just get mold okay
gold foil that doesn't give anything
away okay
doesn't have to be edible because you're
poisoning the person you're giving this
I mean I'm a little distracted by the
piece and syrup I forgot the rest of the
ingredients I'm gonna read them again
yeah oh yeah no worries it's fine Julian
syrup cocoa powder coconut oil coconut
butter yeah in syrup that's it yeah but
also syrup and gold flakes in gold foil
what else was it coconut butter coconut
oil cocoa powder syrup a mold and oil in
a sifter but those are just tools cocoa
powder uh-huh cocoa butter hmm and then
coconut oil are you making like a oh you
know what it's for a dietary restriction
- that's what that's what there's a
wrench in here cocoa butter is that like
they come that you put on your body no
no no yeah wait
I don't know is it cocoa butter gives a
creamy texture gold flakes no for the
mold foil this like a Hershey's kiss
very close very close but there's no
sugar as you can tell so it might be a
certain but there's syrup oh that's true
then this isn't accurate
whatever you can also use honey it says
but that would make three how she's
kisses okay that's a good guess you're
wrong what is it good yes
sugar free um what are the Jewish coins
called gelt
belt Paleo gal paleo what why did you
ever type paleo gelt into Pinterest
because I was looking for recipes Julian
recipe ideas
Julian hey that was a good one
paleo guilty bet you pretty much guess
that was a good winner it was fun so
well I like that laughs okay yeah last
one I have to read a novel okay six
pounds of apples okay one tablespoon of
cinnamon half a teaspoon of ground
nutmeg damn it it just scrolled me all
the way to the top because an ad popped
up okay allspice fourth teaspoon of
allspice nutmeg cinnamon 1 cup of sugar
granulated 1 cup of sugar brown the end
that's it Matt is it American
gluten-free vegetarian but apparently
not you making apple crisp with no Apple
crisps there's baked apples think again
author's name is Lauren okay that does
not help a little time to cook prep time
is 10 minutes guess how long the cook
time is 12 hours 12 hours 12 hours
stewed apples close you like I brought
some home when I went to Tennessee is it
moonshine no that is so wrong how would
I make moonshine with apples can't you
make moonshine with fruit but you need
like the alcohol part are you just firm
into further keep it just ferment fruit
but it wouldn't take 12 hours taste long
it yeah it looks like 12 years but also
you need like you don't need sugar - I
brought some home for Tennessee is it
like apple candy close sort of close
though apple sauce close oh my god it's
gonna be okay 12 hours it will make
apple sauce
so much faster yeah but think about
what's very close to have sauce apple
cider no further that was colder some
sort of like stewed apple almost is it
cuz it hot
no serve it room temp I don't know apple
butter
oh good guessing though that was you
were very close
apple butter apple butter is so good YUM
tastes like apples yeah it's like a baby
food texture but like it's richer than
apple sauce fun yeah but unlike what you
would put yeah it's like a sweet little
thing you could spread on toast so you
can kind of put it on like a bowl of I
don't know like granola or fruit or
something like that it's like fine or
you take it to the spoonful to the face
like I do with almond butter hit him
with the apple butter make him leave
okay well there we go
that was fun that game is so fun it's a
fun game and we should play it more
honestly shouts out to Veronica Ronny
underscore s Esquivel on Twitter for
suggesting that that was a great idea I
appreciate it I just think that that's
so fun it's really big it's like going
in one direction and then it just
doesn't it goes somewhere else I should
have picked a holiday gruel [ __ ] okay
I'm gonna do another one ready rice
water blue syrup gold syrup Hanukkah
gruel Hanukkah gruel huh gruel okay
that's we're gonna end it on her gruel
thank you guys for listening to our
holiday recipe guests podcast and thank
you as always for spending your Mondays
with us we appreciate you you know you
got next Monday with another episode of
something on the podcast woo
have a good one bye bye
[Music]